Hasta no hace mucho, inclusive gran
parte de los odontólogos hoy día piensa
y sigue pensando que el bruxismo es por
una mala posición de los dientes. Y es
que esta teoría tuvo muchos años de ser
aceptada por el gremio odontológico.
Básicamente por eso estás hablando con
un ortodoncista, porque pensábamos que
al acomodar los dientes o al dejar la
mandíbula en una mejor posición, ya no
ibas a abruxar. La evidencia científica
ha venido a aclararnos que el bruxismo
hoy día no es una enfermedad por sí
misma, no es una condición que aparece
por generación espontánea o como
creíamos muchos de nosotros en el caso
de los niños por parásitos o en el caso
de los adultos, el bruxismo del sueño,
por ejemplo, por estar muy cansado y
quedarte dormido y de esta manera
apretar los dientes durante la noche.
Yeah.